ein wunderschöner morgen erwartet uns
hier in unserer kleinen süßen minecraft
hält meine lieben freunde wir dürfen gar
nicht lange zeit verlieren denn in der
heutigen episode habe ich wieder einiges
auf dem schirm was ich machen muss
zuallererst wird mir die kommentare
geschrieben luca du hast deine
margarethen unten rechts im inventar von
daher können wir auch direkt die folge
beginnen mit einer kurzen schrecksekunde
für die verstorbenen tiere also danke da
auf jeden fall an euch und eure
zahlreichen tipps und hinweise dass sich
ja die margeriten und nimmer inventar
habe die benötige ich jetzt allerdings
nicht mehr die porzellan sternchen auch
nicht und meine eichen setzlinge auch zu
beginn der folge jetzt erst mal nicht
denn wir konzentrieren uns erstmal auf
unser schön
nein du willst ein zombie das ist nicht
der wille da unten bei mir war es
wirklich gut auf ich bin irgendwie
wieder zurückverwandeln zu meinem
ursprünglichen wird
ich werde hier vorne allerdings erst mal
kurz mal hin bauen so dass er hier nicht
hoch kommt denn mein schwein hier erneut
eine entschuldigung ein schäfchen steht
ja immer noch hier von daher werde ich
erstmal ganz kurzen weg nach draußen
bauen sodass sich das schaf auf jeden
fall hier nach oben lotsen kann also
einmal hierdurch bitte zack und noch ein
hör- und beim erst auf jeden fall oben
ich gebe ihm das weizen er wird ja auch
nicht mehr runter fallen hoffe ich mal
hier das ist jetzt natürlich blöd dass
das genau beim weg war aber da muss mal
kurz warten mit gras drauf weg ja das
wird auf jeden fall den quartal
geschrieben dass ich das schaf holen
soll das maiglöckchen wurde mir
geschrieben was mir auch geschrieben
wurde war luca du hast hier hinten noch
immer eine diamant rüstung auf dem
ständer die ist fast die ist extrem
die ist wirklich ziemlich kaputt leider
von daher war ich jetzt gerade mal
unsere kisten kripp und habe mir die
diamanten geholt die ja auch schon unten
im inventar sind wir haben einfach ein
verdammtes weg davon
deswegen können wir jetzt mal ganz kurz
unsere richtung
das war es dann auch mit unserem anbaus
ich habe mir gerade mal kurzen neuen
anbaus getrachtet den kann ich jetzt
auch mal kurz nehmen und hier vorne
einfach wieder platzieren sodass wir den
rest unseres rüstung auch mal eben ganz
kurz zurückholen können dann haben wir
auf jeden fall wieder einen vernünftigen
schutz gegen kratzer und so weiter und
so fort also dass hier mal ganz kurz
wieder ausziehen die diamant rüstung
angezogen dann kann ich auch unsere
reisen rüstung hier auf unseren rüstung
stellen neben draufpacken zack zack zack
und sackte damit die hier auf jeden fall
noch am start für die irgendwann mal
reparieren wollen dass wurden auf jeden
fall auch noch geschrieben dass ich das
mal reparieren soll was mir
aufgeschrieben wurde bei luca
verschwendet so viele steine und dem
kann ich angeblich mit einer schwein
säge entgegenwirken deswegen würde ich
sagen ich plötzlich die stein sega jetzt
provisorisch erstmal kurz hier vorne da
wurden auch noch geschrieben dass ich
mit einem schwein säge mit einigen
village quarz handeln kann was er für
unsere strandvilla demnächst eventuell
interessant sein wird ich werde mir
allerdings jetzt erst mal an ganz kurz
angucken wie das hier funktioniert denn
man kann ja nie steine reinpacken jetzt
kann ich sagen ich hätte gerne einen
stein ziegel und dass das zieht nur ein
stein
weil wenn ich jetzt theoretisch so eine
steinige treffen nehmen
optimisten nicht früher gesagt ich hab
mir stundenlanges farmen ersparten
können ihr seht unten inventar
allerdings bereits dass ich mir wieder
einige extra gemacht habe und einige
fichten setzlinge am start habe und mich
auch hier vorne zu unseren brötchen mal
ganz kurz hin bewegen denn wir fahren
nur über zu unserer tier insel necker
baum in will damit benötigen wirklich
eine menge fichtenholz denn ich möchte
heute die folge nutzen um einerseits ein
bisschen in diese reparatur zu machen
beziehen das ist gar keine richtige
insel reparatur aber das was ich gerade
zum beispiel schon vieles gemacht habe
in die richtung eine steinen säge mal
machen oder das schaf unten raus und es
ist ja auch einer gewissen form der
insel reparatur allerdings möchte ich
die heutige folge nutzen um mir wirklich
jetzt endlich mal die ganzen sachen
anstatt zu holen die ich für den
leuchtturm brauche deswegen seht ihr
schon ich befinde mich auf der insel um
eine menge fichtenholz abzubauen und
benötigen davon wirklich ganz ganz viele
willst ich liebe fichtenholz und wir
befinden uns auch hier vorne denn mir
wurde und in die kommentare geschrieben
in lucka dass das grab auf seiner
heimatinsel auf jeden fall stehen denn
die tiere die dort ja vergraben liegen
die sind ja auch dort gestorben was ich
allerdings hier machen soll ist dass ich
dieses grab für die tiere nutze die hier
auf der insel sterben deswegen da wurde
mir auch in die kommentare geschrieben
luca nennen doch das hier vorne einfach
friedhof der kuscheltiere das ist
anscheinend ein horrorfilm ihr wisst
glaube ich dass ich auch auf film über
alles hasse ich verstehe nicht wie man
sich sachen angucken wo man sich
fürchtet ich verstehe das prinzip
achterbahn nicht wird zeit geld dafür
damit du angst hast allerdings wurden
auch noch geschrieben dass hammelfleisch
in der man läuft nicht auf gräbern romy
gutgeschrieben das haben wir fleisch
kein kaninchenfleisch sondern schaafs
fleisch und das kaninchen schild hier
ist dementsprechend bisschen unnötig da
kein kaninchen bisher hier auf der insel
ist was hätte verstärkt verstorben
werden können seien
also dass sie vorn haben wir auch
erledigt der mit friedhof heißt auf
jeden fall friedhof der kuscheltiere wir
sehen auch schon die sonne geht ein
wenig unter von daher euch eine ganz
kurze time lab wie ich eine menge holz
abbaue
[Musik]
warum laufen mir immer tiere in mein
schwert da mache ich hier gerade das
grab fertig von dem kaninchen hier weil
es gar nicht gestorben ist jetzt völlig
neu ist hier das kann doch nicht wahr
sein das möchte ich es mit den mit den
sachen die ich habe ja gar keine kisten
darunter gehalt das jetzt einfach mal
ein paar das bei mir zu hause in die
kisten und schreibt jetzt erst mal hin
hier ruht die kuh ich denke nicht dass
die eineinhalb bis zwei decks
fichtenholz sich gerade geholt habe
reichen sollten für das projekt was ich
heute vor habe ich schon wie eine
schildkröte mein brötchen
allerdings lasse ich die anderen bäume
die ich dort hinten neu gepflanzt habe
die fichten wollen jetzt erstmal ein
bisschen wachsen denn ich mache erst vor
kurzem weg wieder neu fertig das ist ja
alles wieder gewachsen ist es sehr schön
wir müssen in die hölle wollte ich
gerade sagen um die nächsten sachen zu
holen von daher laufen weil man hier
vorne schnell unseren weg lang können
auch hier den weg noch mal eben kurz neu
machen sieht schritt auf unserem weg
vorne drauf was wir allerdings so rüber
müssen jedoch zuvor noch mal ganz
schnell ein goldenes körperteil und
unseren körper packen denn ihr wisst die
leute feiern dort gold und dann
begreifen die uns nicht an wenn wir im
netter sind allerdings sind wir zurück
wir waren lange nicht mehr hier fünf
sekunden dar und direkt hier wieder
unter vorne brennt direkt einer das kann
es allerdings egal sein meine lieben
freunde denn wir befinden uns hier im
nada gegen netter ziegeln die benötigen
wir ebenfalls für den leuchtturm ihr
denkt euch wahrscheinlich luca gemein
ist doch du brauchst einfach nur weiße
und rote wolle für den leuchtturm jahr
ich bin allerdings ganz ehrlich da muss
ich auch einfach auf euch hören die
wolle hätte wirklich angefangen zu
brennen wenn da irgendwas ab gegangen
wäre wenn wir irgendwann auch einmal ein
gewitter haben sollten in unserer welt
wenn wir unser ganzer erleuchtung
abgebrannt und ich glaube das wäre nicht
so heiß gewesen von daher laufen wir
zurück zu unserer festung da haben wir
auch noch immer nicht alles entdeckt
allerdings gehe ich dem leser immer so
ein bisschen aus dem weg weil das
natürlich schon furcht einflößender ort
ist hier mit dem ganzen feuer mit der
ganzen lava und so wir unsere hobbys
greifen uns nicht an denn wir haben den
goldenen harnisch allerdings sieht ihr
schon wir sind hier angekommen und wenn
ich das hier abbaue sind das netter
ziegel in ganz kurzer tablets wie ich
mir davon einige hole
[Musik]
so wir sind wieder in unserer welt zu
hause angekommen ihnen die immer wenn
wir ankommen fängt gerade die nacht an
das irgendwie nicht so nice das mal ganz
schnell die man eben zurückspringen ihr
seht schon und im inventar ich habe ein
steak beziehungsweise noch ein zweites
taxi ist decke vorne von netter ziegel
mir holen können da es geht direkt
wieder los ist wieder so ein idiot mit
gabeln
ich habe auf jeden fall noch ein
bisschen quarz mitgenommen das habt ihr
ganz unten im inventar eingeblendet
gesehen dass benötigen nämlich für einen
tages lichtsensor was er genau mit dem
machen werden erfahrt in der nächsten
folge denn ich werde es heute auf gar
keinen fall schaffen den leuchtturm zu
bauen das wird viel zu lange dauern denn
wir müssen auch erst mal nimmt der fall
wie kann denn können überall noch
monster che mich würde es nicht wundern
wenn das jahrelang über von gekommen na
ja wir haben auf jeden fall eine menge
netter ziegel am start und die benötige
ich um mir erstmal eine menge netter
ziegel sachen zu machen für den
leuchtturm zu allererst mache ich mir
allerdings kurz den tageslicht sensor
den stellen wir nämlich so hehr und
dieser tageslicht sensoren das ist das
neiße
der wird uns zeigen wann tag ist und
danach das ist es logisch dass sie mir
zwar selber auch allerdings wird der
dann licht anschalten leuchtturm
beziehungsweise wieder abschalten mit
den netter ziegeln brauchen wir erst mal
ganz kurz
17 stück an sich nämlich 10 317 stück
und dann müssen wir uns noch acht meter
ziegel stufen machen da mache ich mir
jetzt einfach mal 12 mal anders geht es
gerade nicht wir brauchen 26 mauern also
1 2 3 4 5 dann haben wir 30 mauern und
benötigen noch 32 netter ziegel treppen
das mache ich jetzt einfach mal so 1 2 3
4 5 6 7 8 dann habe das mit den major
siegern auf jeden fall schon mal fertig
ihr seht doch und in einem inventar
ich habe mir eine truhe geschah mal
gemacht beziehungsweise 2 die werde ich
nicht mal ganz kurz die vorne hinsetzen
und hier werde ich alle sachen drin
lagern die wir für den leuchtturm
benötigen also die nutzer ziege sachen
haben wir wir haben den tageslicht
sensor und wir haben 29 jetzt einfach
mal drin wir brauchen es mal nur 14
allerdings haben wir die erste ladung
auf jeden fall schon mal fertig das
nächste was sie benötigen ist auf jeden
fall eine menge roter und weißer beton
und dafür benötigen wir erstmal eine
menge kies also eine ganz kurze time
letztlich zu unseren kiez bergen laufe
[Musik]
so meine spitzhacke jetzt kaputt ich
noch mal eben schnell das bett hier mit
ich habe wirklich eine menge kies ohne
menge steine abgeformt hier gerade plus
auch noch zum glück ein bisschen an die
sieht gefunden denn an die seite seiner
der blöcke den ich wirklich über alles
hasse die mich dann allerdings bei denen
ich dann allerdings bei solchen
projekten dann trotzdem irgendwie immer
brauche für polierte an die sieht
treppen für polierte an die sieht stufen
da hingebaut sich unsere strandhaus
villa auf die irgendwie mittlerweile
wirklich länger heute bediener flughafen
von einer ganz kurzen teilweise mich die
ganzen sachen jetzt verarbeitet so ich
habe mir gerade noch eine menge mit
meinem fichtenholz gemacht wir brauchen
allerdings noch immer ein bisschen mehr
dafür habe ich auch schon fichten
setzlinge mir ins inventar gepackt hier
ist die biene händchen und wir reisen
noch mal eben kurz rüber zu tieren sie
beziehungsweise bauminseln wieder das
brötchen hier vorne zwar zurück setzen
sagt und für die etwas schönere ansicht
wir müssen noch ca 3 4 fichten fällen
danach haben wir auf jeden fall genug
von dem fichtenholz things und danach
müssen wir uns nur noch an die sache mit
dem beton setzen und ein bisschen stein
ziegelstein einzige sollte allerdings
eher kein großes problem sein denn wir
haben ja immer noch wieso hab ich denn
hier keinen neuen 17 hingesetzt ich
idiot war gut da für mich extra noch ein
bisschen knochen mir mit am start
das problem ist dass wir das gute ist
dass wir mittlerweile ja die steinen
sega haben so dass das mit den steinigen
auf jeden fall ein bisschen schneller
gehen sollte ich brauche hier vorne
allerdings jetzt erst mal noch ein
bisschen holz ab der hier vorne kommt
nicht so richtig runter
und dann blende ich euch jetzt auch noch
mal ganz kurz ein weil ich glaube dass
ist wirklich nicht spannend dass es
generell heute wieder eine folge die
wirklich nicht so spannend zum zuschauen
ist allerdings kriegen wir eine menge
gebacken und die nächste folge wird
dafür um so gailer denn hier wächst gar
nichts hier ist nichts gewachsen
wenn hier ist noch ein aber sonst
wirklich nichts was ich tat sagen wollte
war das ist heute ein bisschen
langweiliger ist und ein bisschen mehr
time labs und so dafür morgen er wird
übermorgen kommen die folge wird umso
besser
wir bauen den leuchtturm und darauf
freue ich mich wirklich schon sehr toll
[Musik]
so ich muss hier vorne noch mal eben ein
wenig was beraten und zwar noch eine
menge stein ihr seht allerdings schon im
inventar ich habe schon eine menge stein
ziegel herstellen können
mit meiner stein säge davon also danke
danke danke da auf jeden fall immer für
den tipp das hat mir echt im kompletten
projekt eine menge arbeit gespart wenn
ich das früher gewusst hatte
wahrscheinlich habe jetzt auch direkt zu
beginn schon rein geschrieben nur ich
idiot habe natürlich nicht wieder alle
kommentare checken können weil es so
unfassbar viele sind und da will ich
mich wirklich wirklich beschweren
darüber das freut mich extrem das hier
sind schon alle sachen die ich mir
bisher vorbereitet habe ich habe auch im
inventar seht ihr schon ein bisschen
gelben farbstoff und auch schon weißen
farbstoff dass sie ganz einfach daran
denn unser boot steht ja vorne und nicht
hier wäre da kann etwas gesagt aber hat
es nicht unser boot steht hier vorne und
deswegen müssen wir auch ganz kurz hin
denn wir müssen uns in richtung blumen
bio mal wieder bewegen denn ich benötige
eine menge rote blumen und weißer
blümchen und zwar maiglöckchen denn nur
mit maiglöckchen und mit knochen können
wir uns weißen farbstoff holen genommen
ist ein bisschen umständlich dafür
müssen wir die hürde gehen und so weiter
und so fort
deswegen hab ich mir gedacht und auch
eine ganz kurze tablets für euch wie ich
mir jetzt rote blumen und weiße blumen
holen
[Musik]
so ich habe mir gerade jetzt mal eine
menge blumen hier am start wo holt ihr
seht schon ich habe insgesamt 33 gelben
farbstoff 64 weisen und 64 roten das
sollte jetzt auch erstmal reichen ich
finds allerdings so schön dass ich
dachte ich beende die time netz einfach
mal jetzt schon und zeigt euch das noch
mal ganz kurz mit den ganzen blümchen
und so das finde ich echt mega geil das
ist eines der neuesten biome ganz
minecraft mit den ganzen blumen hier
hier sind ein paar tierchen und so ich
habe mein boot gerade extra mitgenommen
das habe ich auch gelernt dass ich das
nicht einfach ihm wohl stehen lassen
sondern einfach mitnehmen kann ich dann
irgendwo anders wieder einsetzen kann
von daher hier einmal kurz das brot
hinsetzen einmal kurz fahren wir sehen
allerdings schon rechts die sonne geht
schon wieder untereinander werde ich
denke ich gleich mal ganz kurz ihnen wo
man reisebett aufstellen denn heute habe
ich wirklich überhaupt keinen bock auf
monster ich habe mich jetzt fast schon
komplett fertige clip für die nächste
folge wo ich den leuchtturm bauen werde
und da freue ich mich auch schon welche
extremen drauf ich weiß dass ich ja
schon sehr häufig gesagt habe aber der
leuchtturm wird mit eines der highlights
des kompletten projekts finde ich ich
will es nicht so groß ankündigen nicht
dass er zu große erwartungen geschürt
werden ihr wisst ja ich bau lieber
sachen ein bisschen kleiner so ein
bisschen schöner bisschen detailreicher
und deswegen freue ich mich halt extrem
darauf weil das portal schwert ja auch
so in die richtung geht also klar man
kann das portal noch riesiger baut und
so weiter und sofort nur noch pro voller
allerdings wenig das passt einfach
perfekt und der leuchtturm auf die
andere insel das ist ja wirklich schon
ziel seit beginn des projekts quasi ich
habe ja immer wenn ich irgendwelche
schafe gesehen habe habe ich meine
schere mitgenommen ich hab sie auch
jetzt gerade wieder dabei obwohl ich
mich dann letztendlich doch dagegen
entschieden habe dass mit einem mit mit
wolle zu machen
denn wenn wirklich ein gewitter kommt
oder wenn da mal irgend ein waldbrand
ist oder so auf der insel gut er wird
jetzt kein waldbrand sein da sind zwei
drei bäume auf der insel
aber dann sind auf jeden fall mit beton
saved von daher euch nochmal eine ganz
kurze aller allerletzte teil meiner
lieben freunde wie ich zurück zu meiner
insel fahren mit den rest zusammen suche
für das morgige video
bis gleich mädels
[Musik]
da haben wir jetzt alles fertig meine
lieben freunde ich habe mir sogar viel
zu viel sand geholt und viel zu viel
kiefers ich hab noch 460 viereinhalb
stacks kies habe ich noch übrig ich habe
noch ganz viel sand übrig ist allerdings
auch schon mal im inventar wie gehabt
dass gerade gesehen dass ich mir eine
menge beton gerade noch gemacht habe den
wir halt benötigen für den leuchtturm
dort hinten und die sache ist jetzt
allerdings dass das ja trocken beton ist
das heißt ich muss dem beton auf jeden
fall auch noch mit wasser in verbindung
bringen ich hoffe meine kiste hat platz
für die ganzen sachen allerdings ist
alles drin und das war's ich habe hier
rechts mal wieder eine riesige notiz
gemacht was ich alles benötigen wir
haben alles am start wie ein tages nicht
sensor ist der leuchtturm bei tag schön
energie spart gibt's mal in minecraft
nicht aber ich dachte mir echt coole
idee und nur nachts über halt
dementsprechend leuchtet das alles wird
mit redstone verkabelt werden
eisengitter für außen wir haben gelbe
glasscheiben so dass das licht gelb ist
und nicht weiß
wir haben eine menge roten und weißen
trocken beton der nächsten folge muss
erst mal direkt zu beginn eine riesige
times kommen wie ich den ganzen trocken
beton normalen beton mache und wieder
abbauen glaube es wird ein bisschen
eklig wenn ihr tipps tricks gewohnt in
die kommentare allerdings habe er noch
eine menge steigende menge fichtenholz
sachen wir haben eisentüren unten rein
zu kommen
die einzige sind dafür dass besondere
kleinen keinen unterbau errichten werden
und darauf wird der leuchtturm stehen
wir haben netter ziegel treffen zur
dekoration ich aber wieder viel zu viel
ich habe auf jeden fall alles am start
meine lieben freunde die beiden sind ja
auch am start die denken sich auch was
war das hier findet chaotische folge was
soll das hier wieder findet lange volk
ich bin bei zwei stunden ich das video
jedoch definitiv zu spät kommen also
wenn ihr das video gerade sehen sollte
wenn es online gegangen ist definitiv
ein paar minuten zu spät angegangen
seien es tut mir leid hat sollte
eigentlich ein kürzerer episode werde
nicht absehbar auch kürzer für mich war
sie allerdings genau so lange ich habe
nur metall netzes gearbeitet aber sonst
werden habe ich echt ein bisschen
langweilig gewesen also wenn es euch
gefallen an meiner lieben freund und
einen daumen hoch und ein video hier
abonnieren einen kanal und klickt auf
die glocke wenn ihr dann
benachrichtigung bekommen möchte sobald
ich ein neues video hoch wird übermorgen
um 20 uhr wieder der fall sein und ich
die zu viel geredet die zusammenschnitte
[Musik]